[موسيقى]
[تصفيق] تم
إلغاء عيد الميلاد في
رنين أجراس كنيسة بيت لحم ولكن لا أحد يستمع
سحر الموسم المفقود من
ساحة المهد إلى جانب شجرة عيد الميلاد
والزخارف المتدلية في
مكان ميلاد يسوع الكتابي فقط الحزن يملأ
الهواء سألني ابني عن السبب  لا توجد
شجرة عيد الميلاد هذا العام لا أعرف
كيف أشرح ذلك هل أنت حزين بالطبع
بالطبع أنا حزين جدًا جذر
الشجرة التي تراها ونحن نحفر فيها انظر
قنابل الميلاد الجميلة ربما لا
تسقط هنا ولكن  الجميع يشعر
بالتداعيات منذ 3 أشهر بصراحة ليس
لدينا عملية بيع واحدة لا أريد أن أبقي
والدي في المنزل أه حتى لا
أستسلم للأمل، الأمل قليل في
بيت لحم للشركات المصرفية في
عيد الميلاد المزدحم لا راحة  والفرح فقط
الليالي الصامتة حيث أغلقت الحشود المعتادة
المتاجر والمطاعم وأغلقت
الحفنة التي لا تزال مفتوحة فارغة
وتم إلغاء معظم المهرجانات خلال ذلك
بسبب الحرب في غزة عبر
بيت لحم علامات التحذير الحمراء والبيضاء
بدلا من الأسلاك الشائكة الحمراء والخضراء
بدلا من  حواجز الهدال بدلاً
من الزخارف تركت الجرافات الإسرائيلية
وراءها أكوام من الأنقاض تسد كل
الطرق داخل وخارج الجدران ونقاط التفتيش، وهي
جزء من حياة الفلسطينيين. هذا
تطرف جديد تلقي إسرائيل باللوم في الحصار
على التهديدات الأمنية الفلسطينية، وتصفه الأمم المتحدة
وجماعات حقوق الإنسان بأنه
عقاب جماعي  قطع الناس
عن منازلهم وأحبائهم وسبل
عيشهم عندما تراها فارغة مثل
هذا لم أر مثل هذا من قبل لم أر
مثل هذا العام لا
المطاعم والفنادق والمحلات التجارية،
الساحة فارغة تحيط بك هنا في
بيت لحم ربما لا يوجد مكان آخر  أشعر بذلك
أكثر وهنا كنيسة
المهد سيئة للغاية الأب روحاني
سامور موجود في بيت لحم منذ عام
1970 منذ 54 عامًا لم يرى
موسم عيد الميلاد مثل هذا عيد الميلاد
هو فرح حب وسلام ليس لدينا سلام
ليس لدينا فرح طوابير طويلة  عادة ما يلتف
حول البازيليكا المغارة
ويقف دائمًا في الغرفة فقط الآن يمكنك
عمليًا سماع
صوت قطرة الدبوس، ولا يزال الكهنة يصلون
من أجل إنهاء كل هذا الجنون ولكن في هذه
الأيام فقط الله يستمع إلى ريبلي
سي إن إن
بيت لحم